my guest is in fact Genevieve Luke
women's rights campaigner founder of
Redux it is an unapologetically
pro-woman outlet focused on gender
identity and Genevieve can shed some
light on this phenomenon that that
frankly as I've said on the show I don't
even want to look into because I have
been told and that I've read on
different fora that talk about this
phenomenon that there is a kind of
pornography that is apparently a driver
of the transgender identity that is so
perverse that it it constitutes a kind
of hypnosis where men will say I was a
normal guy I lived to be 41 42 and I was
basically normal but then I fell into
this kind of pornography and it
essentially melted my brain I had a
nervous breakdown now I think that I'm a
woman so rather than have to expose
myself to that and then you know I have
to go to confession potentially my brain
gets melted I can just talk to Genevieve
about it Genevieve thank you for coming
on the show
thank you so much for having me on the
show can you just give not only the
audience but me a rundown
what is
among all of the types of pornography
that lead to transgenderism what is this
hypnosis pornography well you touched on
a good point there there are many types
of pornography that are sort of involved
with the transgender movement
um but hypnosis pornography is a little
bit different in that it incorporates
your lifestyle so typically when we
think of pornography we think of it as
something that is passive that you're
sort of watching but this type it asks
you to sort of change your behavior uh
change the way you dress even to start
taking hormones and it's sometimes
called
Hypno so that's short for a
sissification hypnosis pornography and
you know I myself I have personally been
somewhat mocked for the suggestion that
this is having a powerful impact on men
however uh trans activists themselves
will say things like it influenced them
there's a famous academic who wrote a
book in 2019 his name is Andrea longchu
and the name of his book is females and
in that book he explicitly states that
porn and hypnosis made him start
identifying as transgender so what this
incorporates is as you might imagine in
the hypnosis style things like repeated
mantras
counting down and probably some of the
worst most regressive stereotypes about
women that you can possibly imagine the
speaker will say to the listener or
viewer uh you are a dumb bimbo uh
you want to be a girl you want to be a
bimbo you know just all of that sort of
terrible insulting and degrading
terminology and language which is part
of the point it's part of the thrill
it's that it's taboo that it's degrading
that's humiliating
so I guess the question that I have is
are
is it the chicken or the egg are men who
already have these sexual confusion
issues are they seeking out this kind of
pornography or are they looking at
relatively more tame pornography and
then the algorithm and their own
addiction takes them progressively into
this realm where they know I can't
imagine anybody I I can at least
intellectually understand all sorts of
weird sex stuff but I can't imagine
anybody intentionally looking up a kind
of pornography that would hypnotize them
degrade them and make them you know
chop off their genitals that that is
very difficult for me to grasp so so
which is it it's many things so first of
all I spoke with some of these men who
were trying to escape this addiction you
know it's sort of coupled the hypnosis
pornography is also coupled with the
transgender pornography you will very
rarely find anyone who's just
exclusively using one it's typically
both and in a lot of cases with the men
that I've talked to I did a survey last
year with some of these these men who
were trying to quit and very often they
start watching pornography at a very
young age I mean around 12 12 or 13. and
so the nature of pornography is to
escalate uh you need to keep seeking out
greater taboos and and such for to get
the same thrill essentially like any
drug you know you start out you have a
drink or two right and then you need 10
drinks or you need I don't know heroin
or something so porn is just like that
exactly people are raving about genucel
skin care Jessica from Huntsville
Alabama says my skin looks so soft and
clear I've seen a reduced number of fine
lines and dark spots I found a new
lifetime product absolutely love it can
you sell skin care uses a one of a kind
proprietary flower base developed by the
founder and pharmacist who is a great
guy by the way it's also comes along
with rare Botanical extracts and
Powerful antioxidants for skin care
results that work guaranteed I said I
would not endorse the product if I could
not try it if I were not impressed by
the product and also fellas I know
sometimes men are a little skeptical of
getting into Cosmetics too much even
slightly more men than women use
genuscal and for good reason geniusell's
most popular package is available to you
today for 70 off 7-0 at genucel.com
knowlesyt join millions of happy
customers who've already fallen in love
with the results Plus for a limited time
get genu cells probiotic extract
moisturizer free without every most
popular package go to geniusell.com
knowlesyt genucel.com
knowlesyt and so in some cases
um they had seen it as in as children as
12 year olds 13 year olds many of them
had not sought it out personally for
themselves they had sort of stumbled
upon it by accident which is a trend we
just see with pornography in general and
children viewing it is that they often
don't seek it out but it's presented to
them through things like social media
but there's also men who were just into
pornography and then the escalation
continued some of them were into
cross-dressing for example and it it
just sort of fell into their laps in
that way but there's also the problem of
the algorithm so in cases where this
might be on social media for example it
is on YouTube there's plenty of these
kinds of things on YouTube even that are
not age restricted and so if you if you
follow the algorithm it keeps feeding
you the same type of content right so if
you view one then it starts to recommend
it to you over and over again and this
can cause sort of this addiction and
pornography is known to be kind of
dissociating in that it it dissociates
from your body and yourself and can
cause actual body dysmorphia so that's a
known side effect of pornography
addiction especially among men that it
can cause genital dysmorphia so when you
combine those things it starts to look
an awful lot like what people call
gender dysphoria
so what you're saying that's a very
interesting point
when you're having sex with somebody not
to be too crass but you know I guess
that's what we're talking about here
you're with another human being and
you're both there in the flesh in the
room on the bed hopefully with your wife
and you know in a for the purpose of
procreation but you're there you know
it's the real person that that you have
a real relationship with with
pornography it's just Phantom images
flickering on a screen and so you're
saying it's it's not even that the
pornography gets in your head and tells
you that you're the opposite sex it's
just the very Act of looking at
pornography is an act that denies the
incarnational aspect of our being
the short yeah I mean when you're using
pornography or having sex with yourself
essentially and so there are cases you
know where men have sort of turned
themselves into the pornography that
they are watching it's it's it's a bit
um I don't know it seems to me that with
enough consumption of this and addiction
to it then the men themselves will try
to turn themselves into the woman that
they see in pornography
um so there's there's also a kind of a
pipeline
um through
you know starting out to transition and
then going on to become or make your own
pornography of yourself
wow now you mentioned this is just so
so shocking that I've I figured that I
couldn't be shocked by anything at all
in politics and in these radical
ideologies they're being promoted now
down to pumping little kids full of
hormones and castrating them but I guess
kind of the point of Internet
pornography is there's always something
more depraved and and so I did read an
analysis I think perhaps in the feminist
current about how this kind of
pornography is in a way a meta
pornography because as part of the
hypnosis it it mocks you and degrades
you for engaging in an act that is
intrinsically degrading that is sitting
there in a room with yourself looking at
pornography which is kind of an
interesting literary critique and
something that I would be interested to
read more about except that it seems so
perverse and soul warping you mentioned
before we go that there are other kinds
of pornography Beyond this hypnosis
stuff that that would appear to lead to
the transgender identity what are those
types
well within transgender pornography
there are a couple of genres like forced
feminization so forced feminization is
what it sounds like it's it incorporates
BDSM and so ostensibly the man is being
forced to wear women's clothing and then
you know the the kind of ultimate Act of
being forced to be a woman uh following
that but also they might be forced to
take estrogen
um there's pornography that involves
taking hormones
um and there's pornography that involves
um
surgery even genital surgeries even so
uh also there is something called female
masking
this is when when men wear uh female
latex bodysuits and they'll even Gather
in conventions uh together to
participate in sexual activities wearing
a female bodysuit
um
a latex suit on which there is an image
of a woman
a latex
silicon usually anatomically correct
full body suit if you could imagine I
think I'm transforming into Tucker
Carlson by the way my face has just got
a browser furrowing wow okay that's
called masking
like you're wearing a female female
masking and I can even Point
specifically to a man who has written a
book about this named Tory Peters uh he
wrote a book that was nominated for the
the female the women's prize in fiction
actually two years ago and he wrote a
book about this
um called the masker
um his book detransition baby was
nominated for the women's prize he's
obviously the man I'm referring to him
with he him pronouns but he identifies
as a woman
I know you'd also done some work on a
genre of pornography I assume it's
written pornography given the topic that
appears to be associated with the
transgender movement that involves
children and specifically in castrating
and quote unquote transitioning
children what's that okay so please
forgive me this is a little difficult to
talk about so if I pause or you know um
I did an investigation into the world
professional association for transgender
Health this is called wpath typically
shortened to wpeth
organization we've referred to them on
the show a number of times right they
set the medical protocols for the
transitioning of children and in their
most recent standards of care document
which is the soc-8 they Incorporated for
the first time the concept of a eunuch
gender identity and within that chapter
the eunuch chapter they specifically
cited a website that hosts and produces
um fictional child pornography that
specifically involves castrating and
sexually abusing children to Halt them
in a child like pre-purpotal State and
in some cases some of these stories
actually involved chemical castration
while we know of as puberty blockers
being specifically mentioned in these
stories and then doctors sexually
abusing these children who had their
puberty halted and this story I it
upsets me as you can tell but I mean
it's tremendously important and
significant I think that a organization
like wpass not only cited this forum but
was working with members of The Forum
for over a decade
and I have had trouble I've struggled to
try to get this story out into the
mainstream media because I think maybe
it's so grotesque that people don't
actually believe it or they don't want
to believe it or I don't know but
um it's pretty much out in the open and
the academics who are involved in that
forum and partnered with wpass I have
written several academic papers
involving these men and
basically suggesting that written child
pornography is a form of therapy for
them
that was going to be my next question is
how is this legal it's a it's a form of
child pornography maybe it doesn't
involve cameras and images but it's
pornography it's obscene content it's
obscene content that involves children I
I guess I have so many layers of shock
here because on the one hand you think
okay this should be illegal isn't there
some government body that should be
clamping down on this two
wpath is a very very prominent
transgender organization
the very prominent supposedly mainstream
trans organization is working with the
people producing this kind of
pornography that's shocking and then I
guess the the most shocking thing is
that the kind of stuff being described
as a sexual kink in this pornography as
you describe it that is castrating
children and pumping them full of
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
that's that's now policy at the federal
level
so the thing that's viewed as a dark
weird sexual desire in the darkest
bowels of the internet
that's National policy yeah it's
horrifying and within that Forum there's
about 10 000 written stories so this
form has operated since at least 1998
but actually prior to that it was
operating on Usenet
um and and sharing snuff pornography
through that route as well
um and on that Forum if the 10 000
stories about approximately 4 000 of
them are specifically tagged with the
term minor so nearly half of them
involve children
in particular so my question is why
isn't anything being done about this and
you did mention the legality of this
right because it is written because of
it they are stories this is actually
perfectly legal and that is something
that was done during the Ashcroft versus
Free Speech Coalition decision I think
it was in 2000 or about then
and it was decided then that content of
this nature was perfectly legal right
important to note though
John Ashcroft was the Attorney General
relatively recently in American history
right you're talking about post 2000 for
for most of American History nothing
even coming close to this content would
have been considered legal or or
protected as under the First Amendment
or anything like this it's a very
radical new idea that child mutilation
porn would somehow be protected speech
Genevieve I've got to leave it there
because we're right up against the wall
we have to have you back to talk more
about this people write in all the time
not about this kind of porn generally
speaking but about pornography addiction
about the things you're talking about
how it escalates how they were exposed
to it super young and how it's
destroying their lives so we have to get
you back to talk more about this issue
that seems to be ubiquitous and nobody
wants to talk about in public so
Genevieve thank you for coming on where
can people find you
um I can be found on Twitter at women
read women and also Redux dot info so
that's Redux with two x's Radu x x dot
info where a new site that focuses
pretty heavily on the issues with
transgenderism and how that conflicts
with the rights of women and children
and that's how you pronounce it by the
way is Redux no I was pronouncing it in
the French way maybe the Latin way Redux
uh wonderful go check out Genevieve's
work there and then check her out here
whenever she comes back on the show
thank you so much I'm Michael knowlesis
the Michael Knowles show we'll see you
tomorrow
foreign
[Music]